hi Don my name is Greg and I'm John uh
we're part of real rejects um it is we
know you John okay we have crossed pads
right I was wondering if you no no no my
name is John Humphrey but we have
crossed yes yes but yes you're the
person
yeah from the fangoria Blum House era of
my life yeah yeah yeah absolutely I
didn't know if you would remember that
or not I'm good how are you I'm so sorry
I absolutely remember and what a great
shirt I've never seen you yeah yeah yeah
well I'll just leave this interview now
could you please make some space for me
and Donna catch up we're so sorry to uh
insert myself in here today it's all
good um well it's it's an absolute honor
to be talking with you we uh
we've been loving the series uh so far
and I know we only honestly we had like
45 questions I'm not even joking but
we're like we can't do that so I'll just
kick it off with asking you this there
was something in the penultimate episode
that stood out to me and it was a moment
when Lexi is having a confrontation
early on with Jake and Devin and is
basically saying like we don't even
really have anything in common and you
know obviously there's a resolve by the
end where they do come together but it
got me curious what do you think Jake
Devin and Lexi other than like trauma
bonding what do you think they would
actually communicate about or talk with
about uh together on their own fun time
I think they would talk about the fact
that they all have had remarkably shitty
parents except not Devin Devin's mom was
great but but I think that's something
that Jake and Lexi like even if Chucky
had never been the thing that came and
glued them together that they may have
found some common ground but I think it
was it's a legitimate real life kind of
question to ask I think particularly in
the context of sort of what why material
you know that I thought that that issue
you know something that we try to do
we've tried to do throughout both
seasons of the show is especially
through those characters keep things
touching the ground a bit um you know
because there's so much that's
um over the top about the world of
Chucky it's important to balance that
out with real stuff and we all have that
experience where like friendships even
our closest friendships you go through
bad patches they get tested and any all
relationships evolve and change and I
think that that's you know in that scene
that's the real life issue that they're
dealing with that in the midst of all
this trauma they've all been sort of set
in on different paths that make their
friendship you have to fight for it you
know it's like anything good in life you
have to you know you can't take it for
granted and you have to work at it and
some of these issues they're left
hanging at the end of that episode and
we address them I don't know if you guys
have seen the finale but you know they
they sort of get addressed in the finale
as well oh that's good to hear I mean I
think that's beautiful and I like the
result that they do come together at the
end because at the end of the day they
do survive together and I think that's
one of the strengths about the the trio
of them yeah absolutely and and kind of
segwaying then you know into the
spiritual work the spiritual side of
everything I mean we grew up Catholic
certainly and I know you have some some
experience there and I've loved the
Incarnate Lord setting this season and I
just want to know if there's anything
you know particularly cathartic for you
in the process of writing and shooting
season two was there anything that you
were able to exercise from yourself you
know where any of those confessions
personal yeah big time I mean and to the
point that I'm honestly lightly
disappointed that I have not heard word
any anger from the college Direction
That's So surprising yeah
so you have bigger fish to fry
apparently but it was this really
important moment in my upbringing as a
as a Catholic and a potential Catholic
and ultimately a very lapsed Catholic
and it was something I was at one point
gonna put in the season but we couldn't
work it in for various reasons but the
real story is this it's like when I
would when I got to eighth grade my
parents actually sent me then to an
Episcopalian School wow um mainly you
know just because it was a good school
and they had a great running program and
I was a runner and I got a scholarship
and anyway but it was only once I got
there that I really that I honestly took
church history classes and Bible History
classes because up until then I don't
know what you guys upbringing in the
church was like but mine was very it's
not casual is not the right word but it
was obligatory and like this thing that
we had to do on Sundays was like nobody
liked it and if everyone was in the sour
mood and we had you know but but we
didn't have a Bible in the house we
didn't really I didn't know anything
except what I was being spoon fed by
these priests and nuns in CCD class but
when I went to
that
and anyway it was when I was taking uh
taking a a church history class at the
Episcopalian school that I found out
about the concept of transubstantiation
which I don't know if you are familiar
but the Catholic belief that during the
mass the host the communion wafer the
host and the wine literally transforms
into the flesh and blood of Christ not a
symbolic or metaphoric thing a literal
Miracle we are literally eating the
Flesh of Christ and the blood of Christ
and I thought that's insane so I came
home you know it's like I didn't know we
were what what this seems crazy me you
know I go home we're at dinner and I
bring this up hey I just learned this
thing we're supposed to believe this and
my father said that's ridiculous no
we're not I said yes we are
I got the book I brought the book to the
dinner table and I showed them in black
and white and my father got really mad
at me and he said you know it's just a
real kick in the teeth this is the
phrase you use the real chicken the
teeth when your own kid you know
criticizes you know the religion that he
was brought up in and it was at that
moment that I realized oh my God they're
all full of [ __ ] they're all just making
this up they're all like they didn't
know this and I it was very liberating
you know like because I think I was like
13. very liberating it's like oh I don't
have to take all of this literally I
don't and more pertinent to our
discussion I don't have to take on you
know too seriously this notion that I
because I'm gay I am bad and going to
hell and all the other [ __ ] that the
Catholic so um anyway I just thought it
would be fun for Chucky to Ramble On Us
in one point but I didn't get to do that
but yeah I you know I I work I did it
was very cathartic but at the same time
it was my it was never my intention
making fun of the church to facile you
know because I just thought that would
be too easy which is why I wanted to
make father Bryce ultimately a good guy
and and you know and have the character
of sister Catherine who was the sort of
progressive voice of the church in our
story because and and she had there was
like stuff that we ended up having to
cut but her that character's backstory
you know she talks about the good things
about the church you know she's like
that her backstory was that she was a
wild child when she was younger and you
know just her life went out of control
with drugs and the the wrong crowd and
the Church saved so I thought it was
important to acknowledge in the context
of all this that you know the church
does do good things and there are good
people in it of course you know so I
hope it doesn't come off too facile but
they do have they do have it come now I
don't think so and and and and you know
and because of what you how you
portrayed uh father like with David saw
what that was I think that's apt and
weirdly I think because you you do a
Catholic exorcism in the show which is
something Catholicism believes in and
that it's really implemented well in
here I feel like it actually doesn't
serve as an insult it actually happens
yeah it supports what you're saying and
a strange in a strange sort of way
because it is something of Faith so I
think that's a very fascinating thing to
go down and you've if you've talked uh
extensively about like characters and
protagonists that you definitely can
relate to or see yourself in but one
thing I'm very curious about is what
would you say you personally relate with
Chucky or Charles Lee Ray himself I
think what I relate to about shaki is
his sense of Anarchy I think and his
wanting to take down the sacred cows and
sort of subvert Authority and and
certain you know he's certainly always
questioning authority figures and
cutting them down the size and I think
that that's something probably going
right back to my childhood as a you know
budding young gay man you know
cloistered in this world that was
telling me I was bad and wrong you know
so I have a you know a healthy
investment in questioning the you know
Dogma that's fed to me and I think
that's something that Chucky does too of
course he deals with that very violently
so I don't have to I could just maintain
you know he's my He's the bad cop to my
good cop I guess so there's a bit of
catharsis even with writing Chucky
himself I love writing to Chucky yeah
and I think the other writers who've
been on the show same way it's just like
he's you know he's just a great outlet
for those kinds of impulses and and
particularly expressed with a dark human
yeah I mean I remember one time someone
told me you know that like one of the
most important things for a writer in
Hollywood to figure out writing
something or creating something that
serves as a good vessel for your own
sensibility and I think that Chucky and
the franchise in general is sort of like
a good vessel for me to express my
wackadoodle sensibility yeah absolutely
and I mean it's it's really impressive
to me especially in a time where we have
you know well-worn slasher franchises
like skipping over entire swaths of
sequels and things like that like you
and your you know troop at this point
have kind of been shepherding this for
over 30 years and somehow you know
always embracing you know each element
of the process so I guess my question
then would be you know after 30 plus
years since the original Child's Play
like what is the key to you know staying
inspired and you know continuing on and
reacting to the franchise and its Legacy
without you know
without feeling any of that wear and
tear like Chucky feels as sharp as ever
now as it did before yeah I just have
always loved it I always loved the
character and the older I get the more
grateful I feel and the more attacking I
know I am to be even in this position to
do this so yeah it's just been it's just
been such a blessing in my life and the
people as well uh you know I think I've
really lucked out and gotten to work
with and gotten to know a lot of
incredibly incredibly talented people
but also really kind and nice and and
like-minded people as it turns out I
mean I think I'm good at choosing those
kinds of people but a lot there is a big
element of luck in it but you know I
think we're all very much alike in our
in the sensibility that we're just
discussing so it never it doesn't get
old to me and I think if anything the TV
show has reinvigorated everything as I
as I figured it would I mean that's one
of the reasons I wanted to take it to
television because after I worked on
Hannibal which was like my favorite
thing it was like so much fun to do you
know it just the process of making TV
you know working a Hannibal to me was
like wait a minute we go to a room and
we talk about Hannibal all day and we
get paid it's like I would do it for
free don't tell Brian Fuller but I would
do that
and and so it was so interesting to see
how Brian you know marshaled all these
like-minded Hannibal Fanatics and horror
Fanatics to help Elevate this to a new
level because like I've been a huge fan
of the Hannibal franchise books and
movies since it started just through
coincidence I mean I'd gotten to know
and worked with many times the
dailyrentices you know Dino DiLaurentis
and Martha DiLaurentis and raphaela and
because they knew I was such a Hannibal
fanatic I even got to see like the first
ugliest version of Hannibal Rising you
know when like you know Dino got you
know Thomas Harris to write the book and
so they lit and I'm like oh my God he
actually wrote the script first he wrote
the script first and then and then made
that into a book but um what was my
point in bringing that up
um oh it's just to see how these
amazingly talented people come together
and out comes this amazing TV show I
think what I'm trying to say is I knew
that just like through my fellow writers
fellow directors fellow EPS I knew that
the the collaborative nature of
Television if I cast it correctly and
when I say cast it I mean behind the
camera that it could help make it even
better and I think that that has come to
pass and I think that you know I have to
give a lot of credit to the team because
it really making a TV show really is a
team sport I mean making a feature film
is too but even more so and
exponentially so in in television it's
been awesome we have a great time making
that show really good it shines through
it's what you get that Vibe of a great
sense of community
and I know we've gone in uh we've gone a
little bit overtime here so I really
appreciate for your generosity if there
was just one more just fun question of
course off with um and think I've been
absolutely loving the answers I feel
like we both have it no I could do this
hours two hour podcasters who would say
that do you ever see Chucky ever truly
ending and if ever if it were to end
would you want it to end with a series
finale or a culmination with a movie
like bring in the TV characters I don't
I don't want it
I mean outlive all of us I mean we'll go
on and fall to other hands and hopefully
those hands will be as as you know
enthusiastic about it as all of the
hands that have been working on it for
the last 30 some years but I you know I
I certainly have lots more ideas and
enthusiasm for other iterations of
Chucky television seasons and movies so
um you know it's really ultimately up to
you guys
too specifically
I mean you guys are here redoing your
part literally and in all seriousness
thank you uh I'm much appreciated and
it's always so much fun to talk to
people who you know intelligent people
who like the show I mean that is the
nicest feeling in the world
no it's one of the highlights of the
week especially it is and it's something
that we've said publicly many times one
of the reasons we love the Chucky
franchise is because of the fact that it
does evolve and it does embrace its
previous iterations like there's so many
questions that we just love the fact
that it does change up its genres and it
doesn't ever try to just reboot or
remake yeah it feels like constant
continuation but manages to feel
refreshing over time I'm not just
kissing ass here this is something we've
said publicly yeah and just the way
you're able to take things that maybe
you weren't jazzed about initially and
then make them great like you know
turning going from the voodoo originally
to then having this full-on exorcism
which was one of my favorite sequences
in the whole show like yeah and like in
you know John higham's
um directed that episode and he's such
an amazing director and it was a great
script the the writers of that episode
Nick Zigler and Amanda Blanchard we knew
it was good when we were making you know
this is this is gonna be so great
although I'm I must you know claim that
I I got I was the lucky person who got
to direct Devin Sawa exploding for the
funeral oh no that's awesome was it your
choice to do the repeat because yeah so
it was just yeah I mean just chance
because like certain things get farmed
out to different units and so at one
point toward the end of our shoot I was
doing a a second unit and so that shot
was literally the last thing we did on
the entire show oh that's crazy
and so we did it twice in the first time
like it wasn't great it was okay but not
great and so then you try to figure it
out you know like what can we do we need
to do this we need to pack this in here
I mean like as if I know what I'm
talking about but like the special
effects experts and then we did it the
second time and it was like oh my God
that's so great because we even got
because I wanted it to be as much like
the fury as possible and you know so
even just that we got the shot of the
head like falling down toward the floor
like cassave Eddie said in the period
yeah it was it was a fun moment yeah
that was it that was a real standout and
I love the shirtless photo that Jennifer
Tilly posted on Twitter recently
quite popular demand actually very
quickly the original you know I knew I
had to take a shirt off at some point in
the season yes originally an original
and he was he was of course down for it
and he's like working out and dieting
like all season long or shooting and and
up until near the end what was supposed
to happen it was always scripted that
father Bryce during the exorcism you
know there's like Supernatural wins that
come up and blow his shirt off
but it turns out just like blowing up
the Devon salad dummy it just it's just
much more complicated to do that you
know it's just more forgiving to have
the dummy draped in clothing and so
Jeffrey was like what I've been dieting
and working out like in Maniac for
nothing and I said don't worry
you're taking your shirt off
that's great I hope he gets recast in
season three yes I hope he does and
Bella Higgin bottom two yeah oh yeah
yeah absolutely yeah she's a treasure
absolutely thank you Don for uh giving
us one of the highlights of the Year
absolutely this has been absolutely
amazing and I really can't wait to watch
the finale and uh please shock me Chucky
live on forever yeah and if and if we're
ever in a position that you would kill
us in a Chucky thing you know we would
not turn that yeah no not at all
definitely do it I'm sure everyone says
that but you know can you act well you
have to like say and to send us audition
okay of course we will of course yeah we
will 100 for simple reels to go yeah
that's why we did it
all right we'll take we'll take care now
thank you so much thank you guys nice
seeing you yeah likewise